ASSUMPTION.
IT'S NOT THERE AND GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AS A RESULT, THEY NEED -- WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE NET WEALTH OF
THE COUNTRY.
TOM: THAT'S THE NUMBER I WANTED
TO GET TO.
THIS IS A CHART OF ITALIAN BANKS
AND IT IS PRETTY UGLY BACK TO
DECEMBER OF 1980.
THAT'S WITH A LEG DOWN
YESTERDAY.
THAT CHART TELLS ME THE ITALIAN
BANKS ARE IN CRISIS.
YOU ARE TELLING ME THEY'RE NOT.
WHEN DO YOU FLIP OVER TO WHERE
THE MARKET VIGILANTES ARE?
GUEST: IN MY VIEW, WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS LOTS OF THE MONEY
IN LONDON HAS ULTIMATELY AND
ANGLO-SAXON DECISIONMAKER.
AFTER EXIT, THEY SAID ENGLAND IS
GOING TO BE FINE.
LET'S SELL EUROPE BECAUSE THERE
WILL BE A EUROPEAN BREAKUP.
IT IS THE SECRET ANGLO-SAXON
DREAM TO RAKE UP THE EURO
BECAUSE THEY GAIN MORE BENEFITS
ON TRADES.
I THINK WITH MARIO DRAGHI,
YOU'RE ARE NOT GOING TO BREAK
ANYTHING.
SO I THINK HERE IN MY VIEW, IT
IS A GREAT LONG-TERM INVESTMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ECB STRESS
TEST RESULTS, IT'S THE ONE WITH
THE MOST CAPITAL IN EUROPE AND
YOU CAN BUY IT AT AN ALL-TIME
LOW.
>> EVEN IF IT IS 500 MILLION
EUROS THAT THEY NEED, THERE ARE
RULES THAT THEY NEED TO STICK TO
IT YOU CANNOT SUBSIDIZE.
SHOULD THE EU BE FLEXIBLE?
EVEN IF IT IS 200 EUROS, SOMEONE
AT THE COMMISSION SAID PUT THOSE
IN ITALIAN BANKS?
GUEST: MY VIEW HERE IS THE RULES
WOULD BE FOLLOWED.
THERE ARE RULES UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE YOU CAN DO
PREEMPTIVE CAPITALIZATION USING
STATE MONEY.
GERMANY HAS 70% OF ITS BANKING
SYSTEM AND PUBLIC BANKS BEING
RECAPPED WITH 200 ILION EURO IN
PUBLIC MONEY.
ITALY HAS BEEN PRIVATIZING EVERY
BANK, BRINGING THEM ON MARKET.
I CANNOT BELIEVE FOR A COUNTRY
THAT DID NOT REQUIRE STATE AID
-- EVERY RANKING SYSTEM -- NOW
WE ARE DISCUSSING A COUPLE OF
ILION.
-- COUPLE OF BILLION.
TOM: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT IS OUT THERE.
DO THEY NEED TO BE MORE
DRACONIAN AND DO SOME SORT OF
CRAMDOWN AND LOWER THE BOND
HOLDER VALUE TO GET THIS THING
FIXED?
GUEST: WE SPECIALIZE IN
HYBRIDIZING GLOBAL CITY AND I
THINK THE CAPITAL IS THERE AS A
CONVERSION TOOL IF YOU WERE TO
HAVE A 2008 EVENT WHERE GDP DOES
MINUS FIVE OR SIX GLOBALLY.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS RUNNING AT .0
.5 PLUS ONE AND WE SHALL SEE
WHETHER WE SEE A REPEAT OF THE
29 CRISIS.
THE BANK IS STRESSED TO TAKE A
29 CRISIS AND AT THAT POINT, IT
MIGHT GET CONVERTED INTO EQUITY.
THE BIGGEST RISK YOU RUN -- THEY
ARE YIELDING 8% OR 9% AND
CLEARLY YOU ARE NOT GETTING PAID
EIGHT OR 9% IF THERE WAS NO
RISK.
THE QUESTION IS IS THAT THEY
WRITE RISK OR NOT?
IN MY VIEW, IT IS A GREAT RISK
REWARD.
MATT: COMING UP, CHINA'S
FOREIGN-EXCHANGE RESERVE
INCREASED IN JUNE BY $13
BILLION.
WE WILL TELL YOU WHAT THAT SAYS
ABOUT THE U.S..
THIS IS BLOOMBERG.
♪
MATT: "WHAT'D YOU MISS?"
CHINA'S FOREIGN-EXCHANGE RESERVE
INCREASED BY $13 BILLION IN
JUNE.
SOME ECONOMISTS THINK THE NUMBER
SHOW THAT PBOC DID NOT INTERVENE
HEAVILY IN THE U.N..
BETTY LIU JOINS US.
THIS GOES AGAINST WHAT WE HAVE
THOUGHT ALL ALONG, THAT THE PBOC
IS ALWAYS IN THERE MESSING
AROUND, BUT $13 BILLION IS NOT A
BIG PART OF $3.21 TRILLION.
BETTY: AND ARE MEMBER THE
RESERVES WERE A LOT LARGER
BECAUSE THEY WERE INTERVENING SO
MUCH.
I THINK WHAT INVESTORS ARE
TAKING AWAY IS THEY ARE TAKING
AWAY A LITTLE MORE CONFIDENCE IN
CHINESE REGULATORS AND THE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE SUDDENLY,
EVEN THOUGH THE CURRENCY HAS
DROPPED ALMOST 2% SINCE EXIT --
SINCE BREXIT, THE CHINESE HAVE
NOT HAD TO SPEND MONEY TO
SUPPORT THE CURRENCY.
THEY HAVE LET IT FALL AND THAT
SAYS THE SYSTEM APPEARS TO BE
WORKING BETTER.
THE CURRENCY SYSTEM APPEARS TO
BE WORKING.
JOE: I REMEMBER WHEN THEY HAD
THAT THE PRIZE 2% VALUATION.
PEOPLE LOOKING BACK SAID MAYBE
THEY SCREWED UP.
MAYBE ONE PART OF THE GOVERNMENT
WAS NOT COMMUNICATING WITH THE
OTHER PART.
IS THE VIEW NOW THAT THEY ARE A
GEARING THINGS OUT MORE AND NOT
MAKING THE SAME KIND OF
MISTAKES?
BETTY: AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY DID AFTER THE AUGUST BACK
ALL ARE WORKING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY DID WAS
THEY CHANGED HOW THE YUAN IS
FIXED.
IT USED TO BE FIXED ONLY AGAINST
THE GREENBACK.
NOW IT IS AGAINST THE GREENBACK
AND A BASKET OF CURRENCIES, SO
THEY CAN CHOOSE AND MANAGE
BETTER THE DECLINE IN THE
CURRENCY.
EVEN NO IT HAS FALLEN TO PERCENT
AGAINST THE DOLLAR, IT HAS
FALLEN LESS AGAINST THIS BASKET
OF CURRENCY WHICH MAKES IT MORE
STABLE.
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED LAST AUGUST,
THE GOVERNMENT -- THEY DON'T
CALL THESE OFFICIAL CONTROLS BUT
TIGHTER CONTROLS ON HOW MUCH
MONEY CAN GO OUT AND HOW MUCH
CAN COME IN.
THEY OBVIOUSLY WANT MORE COMING
IN AND GOING OUT BUT THE
ESTIMATES ARE LIKE $40 BILLION
NET GOING OUT OF THE COUNTRY
WHEREAS A FEW MONTHS AGO, IT WAS
$130 BILLION.
THEY ARE DEFINITELY CONTROLLING
IT BETTER.
MATT: WHEN I WAS ON "BLOOMBERG
<GO>, WE LOOKED AT THE SPREAD
BETWEEN THE OFFSHORE AND
ONSHORE.
IT THROUGHOUT LAST YEAR DURING
AND POST DEVALUATION AND THAT
TANKED THE STOCK MARKET.
NOT JUST IN CHINA.
BUT HERE, THE SPREAD HAS COME
DOWN TO ALMOST NOTHING.
BETTY: THAT IS A GREAT POINT.
THAT GAP HAS SHRUNK SO MUCH THAT
IT MEANS TO SOME ANALYSTS THAT
THE CURRENCY IS RIGHT.
IT IS PRICED RIGHT.
MATT: THERE ARE STILL CONCERNS
THAT THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
DEVALUATION AND THAT IS GOING TO
HIT THE EQUITY MARKETS HARD.
BETTY: THERE'S ALWAYS THAT
CONCERN AND THAT IS WHAT
CURRENCY ANALYSTS WERE WONDERING
RIGHT AFTER BREXIT -- ARE WE
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER AUGUST HIT
AGAIN, SO THEY ARE RELIEVED
AFTER SEEING THESE NUMBERS.
REMEMBER THAT IT'S A LITTLE
UNDER A WEEK, SO WE WILL SEE.
MATT: YOU CAN CATCH READY AT
7:00 HERE IN NEW YORK AND 7:00
A.M. IN HONG KONG FOR "BLOOMBERG
A BREAK ASIA.
YOU CAN WATCH IT ON THE
BLOOMBERG TERMINAL AND CATCH IT
ON YOUR SET TOP BOXES.
JOE: COMING UP, WHAT YOU NEED TO
KNOW TO GEAR UP FOR TOMORROW'S
TRADING DAY.
♪